when markets get shaky investors and
economists start talking about the yield
curve you know the fighting yield curve
has been kind of an overhang voted yield
curve yikes
and shorted yields curves can often but
not always predict a recession the
reason when the curve inverts investors
see it as an omen for an economic
recession but what exactly is the yield
curve to understand the yield curve
first you have to understand bonds a
bond is a chunk of money an investor
lends to a company or a government with
the agreement that over time they'll be
repaid with interest the interest or the
amount of money the investor earns
annually per $100 of bonds is called the
yield the yield curve measures the
yields of all the bonds the Treasury is
selling over a long period of time the
x-axis shows when the bonds will be
repaid how many months years or decades
and the y-axis measures the yield or the
interest that bondholders receive
annually here's what a normal healthy
yield curve looks like this means the
economy is expanding you can see that
when the market is healthy longer-term
bonds trade at a higher yield and
shorter term bonds traded a lower one so
in a healthy heal curve a two year bond
might yield 3% annually and a 10-year
bond might get 4% investors and
economists look at the way the curve
bends to predict the health of the
economy so what causes the yield curve
to change shape and invert
there are two levers the first is the
Fed which influences short-term bonds on
the left side of the curve in a booming
economy the Fed raises short-term
interest rates also known as yields
terrain and borrowing they're trying to
limit inflation which can get out of
hand when too many people are borrowing
and economic growth is moving too
quickly but when the economy is stagnant
the Fed often will lower rates to
encourage borrowing right now the Fed is
slowly slowly raising rates the markets
have been trending up for the past ten
years and unemployment is way down so
they're betting it's time to raise rates
and restrict borrowing investor
sentiment controls the right side of the
chart when investors think the economy's
in good shape they take money out of
long-term bonds and instead pour their
money into riskier assets like stocks
the lower demand causes the price of
bonds to sink pushing up the yield this
is an important point the price of a
bond is inversely related to the yield
so in bond prices sync the yields rise
and vice versa but when investors think
the economy is headed for a rough patch
they pull their money out of stocks and
put it somewhere safer like long-term
bonds this causes yields to drop that
started to happen at the end of 2018
investors worried that the global
economy is slowing down and they put
more money in long-term bonds yields
which had been above 3% on 10-year
Treasuries fell closer to 2.5 percent it
sounds like a small difference but
that's almost a 20 percent change this
is the key to reading the yield chart
when short-term interest rates go up and
investor sentiment goes down the yield
curve starts to flatten and it can
eventually invert investors view this as
a bad omen just look at this chart
every time the yield curve dips below
zero a recession follows
so what does the yield curve look like
today here's the yield curve in January
2018 and here it is now you can see it's
flattening this is a big deal for the
markets and perhaps the strongest signal
yet that were headed toward a fair
market but we're not there yet the curve
is pretty flat but it's not inverted
that means for now there's no reason to
believe a recession is imminent but if
investors put more and more money in
long-term bonds and if the Fed keeps
raising rates that could change